levena value up our hand so I made this
on you you know what we are in for a
kiss I come one me My Life Companion
left to go to work and only left and he
never came back and I'm about a month
later they told me that there were three
corpses and all the time
I ain't went they had beheaded him and
stripped him naked my brothers have four
- disappeared into were murdered Odessa
Farris edo edo suteki na de todo esto lo
hacen ellos para que ellos no nuestra
bull in this is all done to try to
silence us so we gather our strength and
move forward it is our struggle and they
will not silence us we will continue to
speak out in our country and around the
world against what is happening here in
El Salvador
seguimos adelante para de anunciar como
Nacional a Internacional lo que esta
pasando en el pueblo
most people in El Salvador historically
were small farmers called campesinos
raising their own crops to feed
themselves over the past century
El Salvador's wealthiest families have
taken nearly all the best farmland from
the campesinos these wealthy landowners
used their plantations to grow coffee
cotton and sugar cane for export many
campesinos have been forced to move to
the cities because plantation wages are
minimal and jobs are few but jobs in the
city are also scarce today over
two-thirds of the people of El Salvador
are either unemployed or underemployed
melanism
the people of El Salvador live amidst
misery and death anywhere you walk in
the city you see it when people in
misery one could say oh but there's lots
of Commerce here people selling things
on the street this is totally false
people are out selling on the streets so
as not to die of hunger delay nutrition
que se Diane la mayoría de Nene
anat melody Reza c'mon you guys this is
the result of the malnutrition that is
found in most of the children in these
communities for lack of food and lack of
employment milk is so expensive that it
is hard to buy the children are dying of
malnutrition and no one wants to concern
themselves with the survival of these
children now Marie endo prácticamente de
dez nutrition poor falta de alimentos
porque no i na d que se interesa porque
esto nino sobrevivir
the few wealthy families who own most of
the land make up an Oleg our key which
controls the politics in El Salvador
along with the Armed Forces many social
movements have grown up in response to
this glaring inequality over the past 10
years hundreds of thousands of people
have participated in groups working for
democracy and greater equality these
groups have included campesinos students
professionals the Catholic Church and
urban workers seven muñeca meant an
unnecessarily alam a llama syrian kalium
the reach of the labor movements in this
country are found in the hunger the
misery in which we live we are
struggling to improve our lives so that
our children can survive and have the
opportunities that only if you have had
well Antonello Fortuna Dada
Kaori Thomas Antony would
beginning in 1979 the Armed Forces tried
to crush the new political movement one
of those killed was the Roman Catholic
Archbishop Oscar Arnulfo Romero between
1979 and 1984 over 42,000 unarmed people
were killed by the military decade in
Luton that mistake limine sold out of
the fury we believe in 1980 the
repression against my family began on
December 20th 1980 they murdered my
oldest brother he worked in the sugar
refinery and belong to the Union there
and the repression against my family
continued now more than 27 members of my
family have been killed
Samiha do demos se nos encanta me
capture a este
in 1984 I was captured I was captured
for being a representative of the
workers and a union member I was
interrogated and tortured
psychologically as well as physically
Ettore de de garis ecologica como we
sang a Yamaka todo el Lateran estoy aqui
esta su mil por que se me oligo a salir
del país cuando por el hecho de
certainly I am here in the u.s. because
I had to leave El Salvador because I was
a union member I was captured by the
army and held in jail for two and a half
years while I was in jail my mother was
murdered so you can see that through the
repression they not only split up
families
but they kill people within families as
well ESA a week us an armed resistance
under the banner of the FMLN the photo
bundle mati National Liberation Front
grew in strength in the countryside
while the military continued to kill
members of the unarmed opposition the
war has continued throughout the 1980s
since the early 1980s the US government
has sent a steady flow of money to El
Salvador in 1984 the Reagan
administration helped elect Jose
Napoleon Duarte as the new Salvadoran
president en las que no cream no me say
my polka C emprender own Presidente
hablando de palma i can't sympathize
with a president who makes speeches
about peace and at the same time as
sending his ministers to the u.s. to
seek new sophisticated weapons
helicopters airplanes more bullets
bullets don't bring us beans or rice
they produce destruction and death
Luciano's and Martin
since the early 1980s the armed forces
have carried out intense bombing in the
countryside hundreds of thousands of
campesinos have been forced to flee
their homes hemos tenido ketamine add
the we had to walk eight to 15 days and
nights sometimes up to months 3,000 to
4,000 people fleeing from the military
who have forced us to leave our places
of origin mr. Khiladi beauty he people
have fled to cities and to refugee camps
where housing and sanitation are poor
LeBlanc young as cappuccinos we cannot
make a life in this city but we don't
have a place to work when the only tool
is the machete and we can't use it here
we are used to making our own life work
in the land the internet that we can't
do that not when we are locked up our
refugee can you
the people of El Salvador in growing
numbers are joining together to bring
about change one movement for change has
grown up among campesinos who want to go
back to their own villages this is
called the repopulation movement it grew
out of people's desperation to escape
the living conditions in the city and
refugee camps an earthquake hit the
capital city says Salvador in October of
1986 as the repopulation movement was
developing it left an estimated 200,000
people homeless including many of the
people who had moved from the
countryside que la mayoría de la
mythical son familia most of the
earthquake victims are displaced
families first is placed by the war and
now by the earthquake this situation is
worsening and now these displaced people
are getting involved even more in the
struggle to return to their places of
origin that erect old monster blood
the military tries to halt returning
villagers and once the families make it
to their villages the military often
tries to keep them from staying
repopulated villages have been bombed
and have sometimes been occupied by
government troops internal ejército
euros euros Montenegro PTO's casa por
casa platic are con la signora platica
the army goes out in small groups from
house to house to talk with the people
why don't you go back to San Salvador
they are the life is much easier the
humble families say about it but sirs we
know that life there you have to buy
everything wood root where will we find
work how can we support our children our
lives our inner villages here on our
land and we want to cultivate it to
support our children through our own
efforts and no longer be sitting like
parasites in a refugee camp where aqui
en la tierra y queremos este ulta Varla
Montanaro if they want to kill us
taking come kill us in our towns but we
will not be entienda Matano no Banga
Matara chemometric immune Adad pero
nosotros no no movin
you
a king and fellow consider that since
1979 more than 62,000 people have been
killed here in El Salvador and more than
7,000 have disappeared also in the
United States there are nearly a million
Salvadoran refugees with little in
response to the killings and
disappearances organizations have formed
to demand that the government stop the
repression one of these organizations is
comodities a group of mothers and
relatives of people who have been
murdered kidnapped or have officially
disappeared one prominent example of
their work was in May of 1987 when
commodities immediately came to the
support of three mothers whose sons had
been captured like a balloon little
seals the capture of our boys was on May
1st 1987 after a worker's demonstration
Jose estimated about I was these three
mothers exhausted every legal recourse
in trying to locate their son's case nav
era una respuesta sobre él para Sderot
de su sino este de CD mohair know how
una well daddy hombre after the anguish
of not knowing the whereabouts of our
son but knowing who had them the Armed
Forces we the three mothers decided to
go on a hunger strike with the support
of comadre s-- we went to the cathedral
to start the hunger strike on that same
saturday we were beaten by a troop of 60
police they wanted to get us out of the
cathedral they accused us of being part
of the FMLN strategy because we were on
a hunger strike demanding the freedom of
our sana
preventing a person Becky is although
there are witnesses to the captures of
these sons the army and the government
have not been able to help or even
respond
no an sido capacidad are una respuesta
como nosotros ASIMO gave me an holiday
until they have clarified what has
happened to the disappeared and released
the political prisoners and until
justice is brought to those who have
assassinated our relatives we won't stop
marching in the streets no diremos t +
ra la calle
labor unions have grown during the past
few years as inadequate wages and poor
working conditions have worsened my
family I am so happy to see my people
struggling this struggle is for us the
poor
with alias we've been on strike for 51
days the management has responded with
threats and harassment
Vasia uniformly a thousand workers have
been fired when we want to assemble the
police intervene and as a result of that
there have been repressive
confrontations between police and the
workers no day support inada mente en
nuestro payees unfortunately in our
country most strikes are declared
illegal as a pretext for taking
repressive actions against union leaders
para tomar oppressor leas contra los de
gente de los trabajadores de Ramos that
we want to explain that the workers
demands are labour oriented and the
government's replies are always military
and violent that is a violent death i
people feel as union leaders our
struggle is not only for those in our
workplace but a struggle of an entire
nation against the suffering of our
people against the injustice is of the
government and the oligarchy of our
country
yes amo in contra de todos la Justicia
despite the repression labor organizing
has grown stronger in February of 1986
trade unionists agricultural workers
students religious groups state workers
and human rights groups all came
together under one organization called
the unts the National Union of
Salvadoran workers one of their demands
is a negotiated settlement to the war
which will put a nothing in below with a
big play in the birth of the unts was
the most important event in 1986 in El
Salvador for the first time in history
our common misery brought us together
workers farm cooperative members
indigenous people campesinos state
workers
I
la when si si knows I do though uh
Oregon is our nose
I see if the unts helped us to organize
ourselves and that is how we formed an
organization to represent the interests
of the earthquake victims represent ARRA
loss in Theresa's day load and if Akkad
Oh Antonio when an SI tiene la tendency
a day there are new groups joining the
unts all the time and we have organized
several demonstrations to show that we
are determined to fight for our goals
most rondo de los trabajos amo despues
TOA luchar para conscious tal nesstra
Raimondo a pesar de Santa de la estación
prep receive a case a via cannon throw
pies loss in de Calista's despite the
repression in our country we know that
our struggle is just and that it gives
us the strength to move forward
demanding our rights even if it involves
risking our lives so that our children
will have a better future
estamos decidido puede no NPA atras
inclues OCA possible rio grande are
maitre pidas quantal dejaron poem por
venir Pinet Rosie hoo-hah Mohsen
the cost does not matter we the workers
will continue our struggle there are two
options we either die of hunger or we
fight and we're going to fight El
Salvador is now the third largest
recipient of US aid in the world after
militarism in the dummy unit in ideas
but now El Salvador receives two million
dollars per day from the United States
government this money comes straight
from the pockets of North American
taxpayers and is used to expand the war
against the people of El Salvador c'est
bien en incremental era contra el pueblo
en San Pedro ahora que no le pedí Monday
favor our Eagle legs him we are no
longer asking favors of the US
government we demand that they stop
sending bullets and helicopters that
drop bombs on our family members who
live in the country that they send us
medicine food which is what we need help
for those of us who are barely surviving
at rubella torturous atrovent a los
diferente cuerpo yeah que algunos Contin
la mayor parte during my captivity at a
secret military facility I was
interrogated and tortured and while
there I realized that emoni
interrogators they were North America
lost a entero Edoras tambien a North
American no tato como Madre let a Simo
we as mothers tell you to tell your
government to get its hand out of El
Salvador i KN el salvador polka basic
yet I think Juan Maciel hacia la mort
Americanos seldom does this information
reach the people of the United States
you have been led to believe that it is
a democratic country and that nothing is
unusual there but the truth is that
every day they murder
capture torture and disappear the people
of El Salvador si si si nos a Parsi say
tortora he says a per se algo salvar a
NGO vir no quit the government accuses
us the groups of people struggling for
our human rights of being members of the
FMLN no coos eres el miembro de la
familia
solamente locate an Reza viendo the
government claims that union members are
tied to the FMLN now Duarte sees nothing
else only the FMLN if he's eating he
probably sees it in his plate FMLN
because that's all he can say de L état
esta comiendo kita en la comida esta
viendo el aire
melon por que solo a ho tienen la bocca
estas implica Sione son para nosotros
these implications are for us a danger
because they can use those excuses and
pretext to take vengeful measures
against us
that is why earthquake victims - are
terrorized por ESO es que los dan
mythical tambien para semo's el tear or
plan conclusions ESO Cimino so lava
three of our co-workers from the Human
Rights Commission have disappeared
several have been captured and
assassinated five co-workers have been
jailed in the mariana prison they have
captured members of our families if the
mas anca to allah mr. Fang jihadis
Herbert Anaya
was shot to death in October of 1987
while taking his children to school in
March of 1988
Alberto Santino was captured and
tortured there is currently a warrant
out for the arrest of Roberto Guatemala
Maria's son and the other Union is
captured with him have never been found
Maria's house was blown up while she was
not at home
nuestra lucha que tenemos no no it is
our struggle and they will not silence
us we will continue to speak out in our
country and around the world against
what is happening here Pablo Salvador a
new car para matar leader pero Saarland
oh my they can kill the leader but two
more will come out the next day they
don't accomplish anything by killing
members of the popular movement yeah it
just grows stronger